Now, let's think about expressions
with more than one variable.
So, let's say I had the expression
"a + b"
and I were to ask you
what is this expression equal to
when "a" is equal to 5
and "b" is equal to 7
Well, in this situation, this expression would be...
instead of an "a" we would have a 5
it would be 5 plus...
instead of a "b", we would have a 7.
So it would be 5 + 7 is equal to 12.
Now let's try another expression.
Let's say we had the expression
"10x - 3y"
And, let's think about
what would this expression evaluate to
when "x" is equal to - 1
and when "y" is equal to 5.
Well, let's just evaluate it.
We have 10 times...
instead of an "x",
we know now that "x" is equal to -1,
it would be 10 (-1) - 3 (5).
So three times...
instead of a "y", we will put a 5 there.
- 3 (5).
And so 10 (-1), that is -10
and we're going to subtract from that 3 (5).
You want to do the multiplication first
by order of operations
that's the convention.
3 times 5 is 15.
So, it is -10 - 15,
which is equal to -25.
And now, you have the next exercise
to practice some of these a little bit more.